in the last lesson we talked about
stalls but what would happen if we
stalled the aircraft and the tail of the
airplane wasn't aligned with the
airplane's direction of travel uh
potentially I think we go into a
spin oh my
[Music]
goodness don't be sad guys we didn't
actually die in this video it was all
done through the magic of Microsoft
flight simulator but now you know how
dangerous a spin can be especially if
you're flying at a low altitude when it
happens happens so because of that in
this video I'm going to talk about some
of the important things that you should
know about spins and how to prevent them
according to the FAA a spin is something
that can happen to an airplane in an
aggravated stall if you mishandle the
yaw AIS during that stall anytime these
two things happen this increases your
chance of spinning the airplane which
means that the airplane barrels towards
the ground while following the scary
Court screw path not a fun time unless
of course you're spinning the airplane
on purpose but anyway you might be
asking yourself what the heck is an
aggravated stall and how on Earth could
I mishandle the yaw axis well one thing
at a time let's talk about the
aggravated stall first if you remember
from the last lesson one of the things I
told you was that when the wings hit
their critical angle of attack and the
airplane stalls the wings are still
creating some lift but not enough to
overcome the weight of the aircraft but
if the air speed continues to
deteriorate and the angle of attack
continues to increase your wings are
going to be producing even less lift in
fact most airplanes these days are
actually designed with a slight twist in
each Wing so that the wing rout is
always at a higher angle of attack than
the wing tip this means that your wing
rot will stall first and you'll lose
lift a lot more gradually so as you can
see this inner part of the wing would be
completely stalled while your wing tip
out here is still holding up the
airplane but in an aggravated stall the
whole Wing becomes stalled and drops
like a sack of potatoes that's why it's
so important for you to learn when your
airplane is getting close to a stall
this is what we call an impending stall
on SES 172s you'll hear the stall horn
and then on Piper chair Keys you'll see
a stall light and then on almost all
aircraft you'll get Wing buffeting right
before the wings drop this is the reason
why one of the first things you're going
to learn during your flight training is
stall recovery first we want you to be
able to tell that the airplane is about
to stall and keep that from happening
but we also want you to be able to
recover the airplane if that stall does
occur for one reason or another but the
big thing that's going to make the
recovery difficult is if you're
mishandling that yaw axis like we talked
about a second ago this simply means
that the tail of the aircraft is not
aligned with the airplane's direction of
travel what happens when you're driving
a car and the backend skids out and the
car isn't straight with the direction of
travel yeah the car can be difficult to
control can't it and airplanes are the
same way we need the air to flow over
all the control surfaces evenly on both
sides so we can control it correctly
that's why you have this guy in your
airplane this is called an inclinometer
and if you can't remember the name of
this thing almost all Pilots call this
the ball and if the ball isn't centered
when you're out flying around the tail
of your airplane is not aligned with the
airplane's direction of travel sometimes
you'll hear Pilots refer to this
condition as a slip or a skid depending
on which direction the tail has moved
and if you don't keep that under control
this means that you're mishandling the
yaw AIS and this can make the airplane
more difficult to control especially
when you're moving really slow or if
you've stalled the airplane and that's
what things can get really hairy it's
already going to be difficult to control
the airplane during a stall but if wind
isn't flowing over the wings evenly it
can be almost impossible to control the
aircraft and that's why your instructor
is going to be in absolute pain in the
neck during your flight training he's
going to be constantly telling you to
look at the ball or step on the ball
because he's trying to get you to
develop a habit of keeping the nose
aligned with the tail at all times so if
you do stall you don't even have to
think about it your nose is already
going to be aligned and this is what
we're talking about when we say that we
want the airplane to be coordinated the
tail is aligned with the airplane's
direction of travel and I know I'm going
to catch some heat for this but I truly
believe that it's almost impossible to
spin an airplane that is coordinated
here I'll show you why I believe that
take a look at what the airplane flying
handbook says a spin occurs when at
least one of the airplane's Wings exceed
the critical angle of attack or stalls
with a side slip or yaw acting on on the
airplane at or beyond the actual stall
now they do go on to say that this yaw
is not necessarily caused by using the
rudder in correctly it also can be
caused because you're not accounting for
adverse yaw that's caused by the
ailerons that's why it's super important
for you to always always always fly the
aircraft as if the rudder pedals are
tied to the ailerons unless of course
you're intentionally trying to slip the
aircraft anytime you roll the airplane
you're creating more drag on the wing
with the lowered Aeron
and this will actually cause the
airplane to yaw in the direction of the
lowered Aeron this is why it does not
matter which Wing stalls first or even
if both Wings saw at the same time if
your airplane spins it's going to spin
in the direction of the yaw let me read
you what the airplane flying handbook
says a stall that occurs while the
airplane is in a slipping or skidding
turn can result in a spin entry and
rotation in the direction of the rudder
application regardless of which wing tip
is raised if the pilot does not
immediately initiate stall recovery the
airplane may enter a spin and that
raises an important question what should
you do if you think the airplane is
about to spin it hasn't started spinning
yet but the airplane has stalled and one
of the Wings has dropped how do you
recover if you said the old PA acronym
you're wrong we have to break the stall
first always always always break the
stall first 99.9% of the time if you're
quick to break the stall the airplane
won't even even begin to spin especially
if you're flying a newer aircraft newer
airplanes are designed so that they're
reluctant to spin and even if you do
start to spin breaking the stall during
the incipient phase of the spin is going
to allow you to recover the airplane in
most cases in fact I've intentionally
spun airplanes quite a few times during
training and this is one of the first
things you'll notice when you start
practicing spins if you don't let the
airplane get completely into the spin
cycle breaking the stall will recover
the aircraft nine times out of 10 this
is one of the reasons why you aren't
even required to take spin training when
you get your Private Pilot certificate
you don't really need it so always break
the stall first and then if that doesn't
work then you can use the old pair
acronym now keep in mind every airplane
is different so it's extremely important
that you know the specific spin recovery
procedures for the aircraft that you're
going to be flying but as a general rule
the pair acronym works for almost all
training airplanes out there I like to
use PE pair because the first step
should always be pushing the nose
forward to break the stall like I just
mentioned but if that doesn't work then
you can go power idle aerons and
elevator neutral Rudder opposite until
the spinning stops and then elevator up
to bring the airplane back up to level
flight once again this is going to work
for most airplanes out there but be sure
to check your PO you never know when you
might be flying an airplane that has
slightly different procedures and there
are no doovers so it's important to do
the right right thing the first time now
the FAA is going to try to trick you on
the test and one of the questions you
could possibly see seems to contradict
the airplane flying handbook let me show
you this really quick so you don't miss
this one on the test if an airplane
spins to the right which Wing or wings
have stalled now once again the airplane
flying handbook says that one or both
Wings can be stalled in order for a spin
to occur but the direction of the spin
depends on which direction the aircraft
is ya because of that there seems to be
no correct answers to this question but
the most correct answer is that both
Wings have stalled and here's why first
of all it doesn't matter which Wing has
stalled the airplane can enter the spin
in either direction so the left and
right Wings only are obviously the
incorrect answer but remember what I
said earlier the wings of our training
aircraft are twisted so that the wing
rots are going to stall before the rest
of the wing so if One Wing stalls there
is a 99.9% chance that the wing route on
the other Wing is stalled as well so
that's what they're talking about when
they're saying that both wings are
stalled and that's part of what causes
the rotation during a spin both wings
are stalled during the actual spin but
One Wing is creating a little bit more
lift than the other remember a stalled
Wing is still producing some lift it's
just not enough to hold up the airplane
I know this is a really dumb question
but I hope that this explanation will
help you get it right when you take the
official FAA written exam and that's
everything you need to know about spin
in the next lesson we're going to be
talking about controllability and when
you're ready to continue with your
training you can watch that video right
here but before you do that be sure to
take the free quiz for today's lesson
you'll find the link to that in the
description of this video and by the way
if you need an endorsement for the
written exam you can get my premium
version of this ground course for only
50 bucks at free pilot trining domnet
and that training includes the
endorsement and also a bunch more
quizzes and tests thank you guys for
watching we'll see